“I would like to here again state that 106
is not, as is commonly believed, a basic predator,
on par with an advanced shark.
SCP-106 is a sentient being, albeit a totally
alien one.
SCP-106 appears to be aware of several things
beyond the scope of pure instinct and genetic
memory.
SCP-106 consistently breaches at moments where
recovery and containment are most difficult.
A fox may see his way out of a trap, but only
a man will wait for his captors to look away
to escape.”
-Dr. Allok, from his paper, On Sentience In
Contained Humanoids
They say that patience is a virtue.
If this is true, it’s the only virtue that
SCP-106 has in spades.
The anomaly known as the Old Man had been
well-behaved for months, sitting cross-legged
in the center of his containment chamber,
his lipless mouth molded into a slight grin.
The Old Man had a reptilian-like calm to him:
Never truly inactive, just waiting.
And nobody else can wait for quite as long
as him.
He could go for years without so much as twitching
if he wanted to.
But not today.
Today was special.
There were no clocks and no calendars in SCP-106’s
cell, but that was fine.
He remembered the last day they locked him
back up, and he’d been counting ever since.
Seconds, minutes, days, months...The Old Man
had all the time in the world, and today,
it was all about to pay off.
October 31st.
All Hallow’s Eve.
The night when ghosts, goblins, and demons
come out to play.
The Old Man almost chuckled at the thought
of it.
What a perfect day for a containment breach…
One of the Foundation Technicians observing
106 from a control room monitor spilled his
coffee when the Old Man got up and started
walking towards the wall.
Alarms went off and guards were dispatched
as a large, dark stain expanded on the wall
of the containment chamber, and 106 walked
through it.
Not that any amount of armed response would
do them any good.
The bullets passed right through 106’s inky
flesh as he strolled down the corridor towards
the exit.
He killed two guards and a researcher on his
way out, just for the fun of it.
He’d been a well-behaved creature for a
long time now - he’d earned an evening of
letting his purely-metaphorical hair down.
And when SCP-106 decides to have a night of
good fun, horror is always sure to follow.
This is the tale of one of SCP-106’s most
infamous and horrifying containment breaches.
Be warned: The following isn’t for the faint
of heart.
You’re about to learn why SCP-106 is still
one of the most feared anomalies in Foundation
containment.
Immediately, the containment site dispatched
three of its best field agents: Agent Park,
Agent Weng, and Agent Drak.
Their task was simple: Locate SCP-106, minimize
potential casualties, and distract the sadistic
anomaly long enough for reinforcements to
come and contain the creature once again.
For the last several years, these agents would
eat, sleep, and breathe all things 106 in
preparation for a moment just like this.
They’d been drilled over and over again
on everything from the creature’s behavior,
to the worst case scenario of what to do if
you get pulled into its nightmarish pocket
dimension.
They were as trained as a person possibly
could be for this situation and fitted with
state of the art Foundation equipment to boot.
And yet, they were still terrified.
They passed through the streets of the nearest
city, where containment experts believed 106
was most likely to head after his escape.
People of all ages, dressed in Halloween costumes
were out enjoying the night.
Child sized super heroes were hanging out
with even smaller villains.
Horror movie slashers were sharing drinks
with cops and nuns.
Countless candy-carrying zombies wandered
through the streets.
None of them had any idea of the true horror
that walked among them.
The three agents went over their training
silently in their minds.
106 was intelligent - more intelligent than
anyone back at the Foundation really gave
it credit for.
It’d planned this; it knew that it could
blend in among the costumed monsters that
were sure to be out tonight.
Nobody would be able to tell the difference
until it was too late…
One such person was a young woman named Alice.
Dressed up as an angel, her experience that
night would be far from heaven-sent.
Her boyfriend had made the always classy move
of breaking up with her right before they
were supposed to head to a Halloween party,
leaving her in a fit of emotional distress
and embarrassment.
Over the course of the next several hours,
she obsessively reflected on her ex-boyfriend’s
audacity and lack of empathy toward her, burdening
her mind and filling her head with anxiety.
His last words, “I’m sorry, it’s over!”
gradually became louder and louder in her
thoughts, as she stumbled in sadness away
from the noise of the streets towards a thicket
of trees.
She was in such despair she could barely stand,
and as she staggered through the vegetation,
she didn’t even notice the shuffling of
footsteps behind her, or that they were getting
closer and closer and closer…
Alice tripped, and caught herself against
a nearby tree.
That’s when she noticed a sudden burning
sensation on the skin of her hand.
She looked up and saw that her hand was now
coated in a sticky, tar-like substance.
Whatever it was, it seemed to be eating away
at the tree, and she could hear the hiss of
the corrosive liquid as it melted the skin
of her hand.
A twig cracked behind her and she turned to
see the rotting Old Man staring at her with
a malicious grin.
She screamed, and began to run, but the alcohol
had robbed her of her coordination.
She tried as hard as she could to escape while
cradling her burning hand, but it wasn’t
enough.
She felt a spike of excruciating pain rock
her nervous system.
The Old Man had reached into her back, like
a man operating a puppet.
His long, burning fingers, dripping with corrosive
grease, had melted through her skin, and grabbed
her by the spine.
She screamed in pain, but she was too far
away.
Not a soul could hear her.
And the only creature that could didn’t
have anything resembling a soul.
The creature grabbed her, and pulled her into
its blistering embrace.
It smiled the whole time, baring every rotten
tooth.
It held her in place, burning the rest of
her body as the two of them sank into the
ground together, more acidic sludge pooling
at their feet.
Alice screamed on, and SCP-106 loved her all
the more for it.
The screamers were its favorite.
By the time Agent Drak, Parks, and Weng found
Alice, it was hard to know that this had once
been a human.
But they knew one thing for certain: that
this was the work of the Old Man.
And they suspected that he wasn’t close
to being done with his campaign of Halloween
terror.
Next, came a little boy named Jason and his
unfortunate friends.
They were dressed as the Justice League, with
Jason leading the group as Batman, all of
them wearing costumes that made them feel
like true heroes.
It’d been a good night, their bags heavy
with candy.
As they walked down an alleyway they’d passed
through countless times on their way home
from school, they had no idea what was waiting
for them.
A long, gnarled hand, dripping with black
ooze, suddenly shot out of the wall and grabbed
the boy dressed as Superman.
He screamed as he was pulled towards the ooze,
his braces shining in the moonlight, and kept
screaming until he disappeared into the solid
brick wall.
The rest of the “Justice League” broke
into frightened screams and scattered.
But they weren’t fast enough.
Hands kept emerging from the wall, grabbing
the children, burning them, pulling them into
the dark.
Only Jason got away, running and screaming
as his friends were yanked into the void.
But no one gets away from the Old Man that
easily.
A black puddle formed on the ground in front
of Jason, and the Old Man rose out of it,
still grinning its malicious, spiteful grin.
Jason fell to the ground, his legs giving
out from the fear.
But the Old Man didn’t move, he just stared
at him, sizing him up, deciding what type
of torment would yield the most twisted pleasure.
The creature lifted something up to its mouth,
something that might have been mistaken for
a piece of Halloween candy from a distance.
But Jason knew better.
It was a tooth, and Jason could recognize
the shining braces still stuck to it.
The Old Man put the tooth in his mouth, and
crunched it like a jawbreaker, as Jason almost
passed out from the sheer terror of watch
it.
To this day, nobody knows why the Old Man
spared Jason.
But when Agents Drak, Parks, and Weng found
the boy, the only survivor from the massacre
of his friends, he was gripping the metal
fragment from Billy’s tooth so hard that
it was embedded into his palm.
But the night still wasn’t over yet.
The Old Man still wanted to have just a little
bit more Halloween fun.
One little boy couldn’t join in on the Halloween
adventures all his friends were having.
He was stuck at home, sick with a stomach
flu that had been going around at school.
All he could do was sit and watch scary movies
as his mother answered the door, passing out
candy to the trick or treaters that he wished
he could join.
He sighed as he heard his mom at the front
door giving candy to pirates, zombies, and
vampires.
Tomorrow would be even worse when he was forced
to watch his friends eating their candy and
reminiscing about all the fun he wasn’t
involved in.
His self-pitying was interrupted though when
he heard his mother open the door to another
trick or treater.
But this time, there was no exchange of words
or candy.
Just a long, blood-curdling scream.
The little boy quickly got up to investigate,
his heart pounding in his chest.
The sounds of his mother’s pain kept echoing
down the hall, as the heavy footsteps of something
else approached.
It rounded the corner, and the little boy
saw it, in all of its horrifying glory, like
something out of one of the horror movies
he had been watching, only worse.
It was the rotting Old Man, dragging his dying
mother along with one hand that was stuck
right into the flesh of her chest and grabbing
her by the ribcage.
He screamed and ran upstairs towards the bathroom,
the only room in the house with a lock.
He could hear the plodding footsteps of the
creature following him up the stairs followed
by the sickening sound of what must have been
the Old Man dropping his mother’s body.
The little boy slammed the bathroom door shut,
locked it, and collapsed against the wood.
His face was hot and sticky with tears, but
at least he was safe for the moment.
Surely someone had heard his mother’s screams
and would come to save him.
As he was imagining the police bursting through
the front door and gunning down the monster,
he heard a hissing sound coming from above
him.
He looked up, and saw the face of the Old
Man, melting through the door and smiling
at him from above.
He tried to scream but the monster opened
its mouth and a tide of corrosive liquid hit
him in the face.
Moments later, someone did burst through the
front door, but it wasn’t the police, it
was the three agents, drawn to the Old Man’s
location by a trail of violence and acidic
black mucus.
And as far as 106 was concerned, this was
a great thing - he’d just finished breaking
his last set of toys, and the new ones were
here right on schedule.
Parks fired at the creature, but it wasn’t
enough to save Agent Drak.
He was standing just a little too close, and
underestimated how fast the creature could
move.
Before he knew it, he was being dragged into
a messy portal in the wall by an entity that
was beyond his darkest nightmares.
When he woke up, he was in the one place that
anyone who knows about SCP-106 hopes never
to find themselves: The Pocket Dimension,
that labyrinth of twisting, rotting hallways
where the Old Man has total dominion.
You’d rather be in Hell, under the care
of the devil himself than end up there.
Agent Drak encountered horrors beyond conception
before he finally, mercifully, died at the
Old Man’s hands.
No weapons or training could save him, no
amount of effort could dig him out of this
hole.
He ran through the halls for four whole days
before SCP-106 finally got bored, and started
taking him apart, but to Agent Drak, those
four days felt like a wretched eternity.
When they eventually found SCP-106, he was
standing in a field, stomping on pumpkins
out of boredom.
He submitted to containment with relatively
little difficulty, as Foundation field agents
used high-intensity lights to subdue him.
Clean up crews applied amnestics and generated
cover stories.
Everything about the Halloween night massacre
was swept under the rug.
Back in containment, SCP-106 once again sat
cross-legged on the floor of his cell, sorting
a little collection of its victim’s teeth
like Halloween candy.
He sat and smiled, mulling over the memories
of his delightful halloween night.
He’d be fine for another few months now,
he could just sit and enjoy the thoughts until
the Foundation got bored and loosened the
leash again.
106 is a patient monster.
When the time came, he’d be ready.
He was always ready.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
and “SCP-3280 - After the Storm” for more
terrifying tales from the SCP Foundation!